hey guys I'm Ryan right Alyssa be crazy
I'm Dan cypher and tonight we're gonna
watch a couple little trailers about
Assassin's Creed are you okay okay
over here is the bubble of crazy and
sighted I love Assassin's Creed I've
played every sin I've pretty much owned
every single one of them except for I've
played it I don't know in it but I will
make sure I live in it you can call this
hotline right here to talk to Melissa
tonight yeah sorry to hoard you out like
that
you not so much
why because I have a kind of face yeah
you got that suddenly farlan thing going
on and that I have the young
professional look going on hey give me
your money yeah so III convention going
on right now and they're releasing a
[ __ ] ton of trailers so we're gonna
start watching a bunch of these
[ __ ] I used to be so many video
games
I met past few years haven't been but
lately with all these trailers I called
her up just to talk about like what I
want to do with buying video game
systems and start going all out again I
was really confused so freaking hard to
get him back into video games and now
what's happening it's gonna be wonderful
well something I was here to help you do
nothing you weren't in that conversation
Wow Wow Alyssa way to make Dan feel
excluded but this is gonna Lisa I was
getting closer but that's okay
all I know is that unity actually
there's four player co-op I need to
prepare my wallet it's right you made a
lot of money tonight
well the prostitution that did pimp you
out for tonight alright let's watch this
I'm ready my body is ready okay this
one's the characters and weapon
you be thought Arno Dorian
[Music]
Arnie's badass the hider blade growing
abilities to the and we're moving on
yeah that was like with a little more
uneventful ones but still that's still
it that's a pretty cool way to pump you
up to be like hey man we got a cool new
character out here here all but all the
ways that you're going to kill yeah
exactly
alright this one this is like the real
trailer here we go and the most generic
controller I've ever seen with this I
used to tailor the trailers go this is
the actual presentation is too smart for
me it's okay just tune out into the
killings mimics oh here it is the
gimmick wow those are really good
graphics you know I'm trying to remember
if this is actually like in game where
what's wrong
you sir the details of that nose get
nose forget about that ass that nose
just loves real people know what never
real yeah they're real
I just love how calm this is before calm
before the storm
oh yeah they know how to make it really
they really do whoa yeah good job bro oh
here we go
oh [ __ ]
and those are the other three even play
as your friends I'm digging this song
it's a really good choice very damn
that's cool says this game plays around
historical fiction yeah
Wow Wow it is it's like a real [ __ ]
Oh Sarah was there with the chills I
know yeah thanks serious chills my
nipples are so hard right now easy but
fine here's all three of them helping
each other now there's the weapon
Wow if the game plays anything like this
combat like
nice image so badass how badass is that
is they don't even fish the dude off
just like you ain't gonna win this and
walk away yes hell yes
first I'll be first first unity like you
and you and me good night it's gonna
happen it will happen the last time they
did not two or three or four
it was Brotherhood and Brotherhood is my
favorite at the entire series thus far
and I think this one is gonna be my new
favorite it looks amazing I want to say
with the UH with the eagle at the
beginning it kind of reminded me of the
beginning of fable 3 Oh with the chicken
a little bit a little bit I really for
from the truth I know plenty he knows
not which I speak I really love that
kind of it's the subtle that's the power
beneath it I just I love it so much and
the song was a perfect choice wow that
was a hell of a read hell I'm what I'm
mostly excited about this is because I
did multiplayer on Assassin's Creed 3
and while it was really fun the problem
was is that I was terrible and everyone
else was really really good and this is
great because now I feel like I can
enjoy my friends and we can take out one
dude that doesn't even stand a freakin
chance and I don't feel like a total
noob at the end of the day
I can be a really bad I know especially
when you say that you uh you have a
gaming channel but you know assassin's
creed's just not what you normally do if
it was Super Mario Brothers you can
forget about it game looks great and the
gameplay from e3 is even just everything
about it is so smooth and it looks great
there's a few like little technical
things during some of the gameplay but
it looks great
it really does I think it's gonna be fun
ya know I just love games that have a
cool and really unique like really
hooking hooking story again ah back to
the jokes call this number down below
I like historical fiction stories a lot
you know for some reason all that comes
to mind x-men first class even though
this is nothing like this but historical
fiction you know inglorious basterds and
now this it blows my mind how movies
have not been able to get it right on
video games when they have like some of
the most bomb stories well I mean it's
interesting because Michael Fassbender
is supposed to be in the Assassin's
Creed movie that's in development right
now I'm sorry I tried look over there
it's a subscribe blood our co venture
eight three two hey guys loved all of
your videos I've been watching for a
very long time can i have a shout out
please well you're just going it mother
and what I appreciated the most is you
asked please yes they say he didn't
threaten to like murder me in the past
or something like that kill your parents
but that was rectified in a very
adventurous time-traveling journey there
was a lot of close calls but in the end
we all came together as family
oh yeah a dark Avenger man you've been
waiting shut up for a while it's about
time you got one man you stay dark and
classy oh yeah what if you're black
that'd be cool
yes again jeonghui herro Rara jolly
hetero Ronnie says that never give me a
shout out yet me brother huh oh wait for
me shout out then I will make love to
your profile pic ha ha ha it's pickup
good job good job
ok so why even way to even make you love
to my profile picture do you really know
how to get to it guys hard probably
wasn't hard to find the picture of this
yeah and don't Photoshop that Internet
too late well John Lee I hope you had a
good time masturbating to me I know I
did every shot kills 29 that's a perfect
YouTube name to have right now shout-out
please also my real name is tamer Tama
Thomas Tom er it's Turkish mrs.
partitioning the Tom er tamer
it's the Thom Ruhe team oh the Tom er
tamer I think it's the mystery yeah just
like the idea that this guy goes outside
it was like Oh lion tamed its mutant
power to just like tame animals now
would be the coolest power actually I
want to rule the world with that power
yeah easily dude tamer
we got a hangout man we got some planets
to destroy you can call this number here
can I do a personal shout-out you have
you since you have a gaming channel have
you heard of Nintendo not intend
oh my god I am so know I have heard of
it
she's like a unique style of cosplay
just for a Nintendo character oh I wanna
give you a shout out Natalie she's been
one of my best friends since sixth grade
and I love that's one of your best
friends Natalie I love you and now I
want these guys to know about you and
yes yeah actually next time you come
down here next time and then you'll do
this cuz it's fun or you know yes
I hope she's down if you know I mean if
you are